I'm gonna set the scene as best I can
last night National Association of
Broadcasters they hold their annual
awards ceremony and they have it in
different cities last night it was in
Orlando and this is where they hand out
local awards to radio affiliates and
host and stations and also they have the
the big one and that's the Marconi award
that goes to the national best national
radio host and I've won at once before I
was up for the nomination last night and
ended up winning we obviously weren't
there in Orlando but Nick Friday Yanni
who won American Idol a couple years ago
friends of the show friend of two-a-days
he's from Connecticut he's been in
studio with us he's been on the show a
couple of times and we two days reached
out and said look if Dan wins would you
go up and accept the award on his behalf
and here's how it played out last night
in Orlando and the winner is dan Patrick
premier networks
[Applause]
so they're not sure if anybody's
accepting on my behalf and Nick Friday
Yanni comes up and grabs the Marconi
award gets a picture taken the host is
Matt Nathanson yeah that right like
singer/songwriter yeah
so then nick is gonna go up and make his
acceptance speech
Matt was concerned that I drank too much
I this is this is planned I'm Nick
Frediani I'm the guy that showed up cuz
max isn't here so nice to meet you guys
yes so I'm friends with Dan Patrick I'm
from Connecticut and Dan's radio shows
in Connecticut I've been on his show a
few times and I got a text today and he
said dude if I win you got a you got to
accept the award so that's what I'm
doing I don't really have anything to
say
dan is happy and he's also at a loss for
words as am I so I'll see you guys soon
I was well done joining us now the
former American Idol winner Nick
Frediani how would you compare that last
night to winning American Idol Nick well
I'll be honest with you I think that the
trophy itself is pretty serious dude I
mean we I didn't get anything like that
when I was you know so I was I was
walking around last night at the bar
with that thing it was an accent people
I was like a big shot last night so I
appreciate it it was like it was it was
great how nervous were you uh I wasn't
too nervous I mean I I was more nervous
that like it didn't seem organizers like
that people do I was like that ran the
show that I was going to do it so I was
worried that like people were gonna get
mad at me and think that I was just
running on stage so like it was kind of
weird but I wasn't too nervous and you
came up with a couple things to say
which was great you know yeah ad-libbed
a little bit I mean I tried I tried my
best but I mean III probably over you
know I I'm actually friends with Dan
overlock but it was cooler for me to say
I'm friends with you so that was okay
well I realized that you didn't give two
days a shout out there that you said
it's just again I was trying to think of
my whole night and I was like I'm gonna
have this trophy I I'm gonna perform
tonight I'm the American Idol winner if
I could stamp Dan Patrick's friend it
kind of goes a little farther so yeah it
was cool I I thought you did a great job
but I you know once you got on stage it
felt like people were going what the
hell that's not Dan Patrick who the hell
is
that they're accepting there did you get
that feeling yeah oh that was that was
definitely because I was thinking I was
like do I say like I'm a producer do I
like write like do I roll with it but I
was like I mean I guess I was hoping
that someone would recognize me I think
that's kind of my job is hoping that
someone does so anyways it was a it was
kind of it was totally random but it was
it was fun I love life how was the
after-party
well there was two different after
parties so there was like the vault
there was two different hotels that were
tennis there's like the old person party
and then there was like the the younger
person party so I went to the old person
party first and then the the younger
crowd to to end the night I don't know
I'm getting your trophy through security
this thing is a pretty it's a beast
and it's pretty good pretty good size
trophy well just to have them ship it
ship it know they left it with me you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna get a I
don't want to give it up listen I'm
gonna get you a mini Marconi for
accepting the award for me last night
yeah I could put it on like a necklace
or something oh no no it's a little bit
bigger can you write a song about the
Marconi and like is there a way to you
know work this into your calling you
yeah I could work I can work a Marconi
line into a song I think if you'd like
maybe maybe two days can work on it with
me we can get something for your trigger
Marconi would yeah he's no phoneme he
won the Marconi mark right and then from
there something like that
I think secular career careers go well
man just you know just I was on tour for
a while how to put out a Nietzsche about
nine months ago working on new stuff
let's do here now so it's a good life
I'm playing music so it's fun
got a website that people can go and
keep an eye on what's going on yeah
everything all social media all website
meetings just dick Frediani I know it's
not the easiest last name of spell but
it's fr Atia and I Nick thank you we
look forward to seeing you back in
Connecticut and again you did a great
job
accepting on my behalf last night thanks
man I appreciate it
thank you Nick Friday Yanni American
Idol winner for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel two three
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]